for most of human history the idea of
being polite
has been central to our sense of what is
required to count as a good and
civilized person but more recently
politeness has come under suspicion it
can sound a bit fake and insincere and
in its own way really rather rude we
often tend to prefer the idea of being
frank and speaking our own minds the
rise in our collective suspicions of
politeness has a history politeness used
to be central to our education etiquette
books and guides to manners were all
deemed essential yet in the late 18th
century the approach was thrown into
disrepute an alternative romantic ideal
emerged in large part driven forward by
the Swiss philosopher jean-jacques
Rousseau who powerfully read ascribed
politeness as an indication of civility
and deceit and argued in favor of always
remaining true to yourself the romantic
suspicion of politeness was given a
further boost by the increasing role of
the United States being direct and open
came to be seen by Americans themselves
as one of their national virtues an
attitude encapsulated in a climactic
line from Gone with the Wind
when Rhett Butler turns to Scarlett O
Hara and tells her exactly how he sees
it frankly we're here I don't give a
damn and because America has been the
world's most influential culture for
around a century and a half its attitude
towards politeness has been widely and
pervasively disseminated around the
planet ever since what ultimately
separates the polite from the frank
person isn't really a knowledge of
etiquette it's not really about what
knife to use at a formal dinner when to
say please or thank you or how to word a
wedding invitation it comes down to a
contrasting set of beliefs about human
nature the polite and the frank person
behave differently chiefly because they
see the world in highly divergent ways
these are some of the key ideological
issues that separate them Frank people
believe in the importance of expressing
themselves honestly principally because
they trust that what they happen to
think and feel will always prove to be
fundamentally acceptable to the world
their true sentiments and opinions may
when voiced be bracing of course but no
worse these Frank types assume that what
is honestly avowed cannot really ever be
vindictive disgusting tedious or cruel
in this sense the polite person sees
themselves a little in the way we
typically see small children as blessed
by an original and innate goodness even
the most etiquette conscious among us
don't usually think that the strictures
of politeness will apply to the very
young we remain interested to hear about
whatever may be passing through these
diminutive creatures minds and we stay
unalarmed by the awkward moments or
negative statements if they say that the
pastor is yuck or that the taxi driver
is ahead like a weird goldfish it sounds
funny
rather than wounding the Frank person's
trust in their basic purity erodes the
rationale for editing or self-censorship
they can believe that everything about
them were more or less proof fine
whatever they happen to say or do the
polite person by contrast proceeds under
a fervent suspicion of themselves and
their impulses they sense that a great
deal of what they feel and want really
isn't very nice that closely in touch
with their darker desires and can sense
their fleeting wishes to hurt or
humiliate people they know they're
sometimes a bit revolting and cannot
forget the extent to which they may be
offensive or frightening to others they
therefore set out on a deliberate
strategy to protect others from what
they know is within them
it isn't lying as such they merely
understand that being themselves is a
treat they should take enormous pains to
spare everyone else from experiencing
especially anyone they claim to care
about the Frank person operates with a
charming unconscious assumption that
other people are at heart pretty much
like them this can make them very Club
herbal and allows them to create some
astonishing intimacy's across social
barriers at high speed when they like
listening to a particular piece of music
at high volume they'll take it as
obvious that you probably do as well
because they're very enthusiastic about
spicy food or never want to add salt to
a dish
doesn't cross their mind to ask if you
actually like this restaurant or would
favor a salt cellar on the table for
their part the polite person starts from
the assumption that others are highly
likely to be in quite different places
internally whatever the outward signs
their behavior is therefore tentative
weary and filled with inquiries they
will explicitly check up with others to
take a measure of their experiences in
Outlook
if they feel cold they're very alive to
the possibility that you may be feeling
perfectly warm and so we'll take trouble
to ask if you'd mind if they went over
and closed the window they're aware that
you might be annoyed by a joke that they
find funny or that you might very
sincerely hold political opinions quite
at odds with their own their manners are
grounded in an acute sense of the Gulf
that can separate one human being from
another the Frank person works with an
underlying sense that other people are
internally for the most part extremely
robust those around them are not felt to
be forever on the verge of self-doubt
and self-hatred their egos are not
assumed to be gossamer-thin
and a perpetual risk of deflating there
is therefore understood to be no need to
let out constant small signals of
reassurance and affirmation when you go
to someone's house the fact that the
meal was tasty will be obvious to
everyone not least the person who spent
four and a half hours cooking it so
there's no need to keep stressing the
point in a variety of discreet ways the
office junior must have a pretty clear
sense that they're making the grade
without a need to stop and spell it out
a frank person assumes that everyone's
ego is already at least as big and
strong as it should be the polite person
however starts from a contrary
assumption that all of us are
permanently only millimeters away from
inner collapse despair and self-hatred
however confident we may look we're
painfully vulnerable to a sense of being
disliked and taken for granted all of us
are walking around without a skin
accordingly the polite person will be
drawn to spend a lot of time noticing
and commenting positively on the most
apparently minor details they'll say
that the watercress soup was the best
they've had for years they'll mention
that that work on a Mexico deal was
really helpful too and was
noticed by the whole company they'll
know that everyone we come across has a
huge capacity to hurt us with what we
foolishly and unfairly refer to as small
things
there'll be an Associated difference in
how the frank and polite person behaves
in service contexts Frank people don't
feel any great need to express gratitude
the waiter or the person at the car hire
desk has they feel no special need of
kindness on top of the money they'll
already be getting from the transaction
yet the polite person knows that we need
to find respect and a form of love from
our work as much as we need cash so
they'll be conscious of an additional
need to contribute smiles and pleasant
word or two
these people are doing their jobs for
the money of course but payment never
invalidate an equally strong emotional
hunger for a sense of having been useful
noticed and appreciated by another
person the Frank person is often very
kind but in a big way they're interested
in enormous acts of generosity and
kindness towards major sections of
humanity perhaps the rescue of the whole
continent of Africa or a plan to give
every child in the country an equally
good start in life but a consequence of
their enthusiasm can be a certain
impatience with smaller moves and
gestures there's really no point they
may feel in spending time and money
sending people flowers writing notes
after dinner or remembering birthdays
when a fundamental transformation of the
human condition is at hand the polite
person also passionately cares about
spreading kindness love and goodness on
a mass scale but they're cautious about
the chances of doing so on any realistic
time horizon yet their belief that you
perhaps can't make things a lot better
for a huge number of people in the
coming decades makes them feel that it
is still very much a worthy goal to try
and make a modest minor improvement in
the lives of the few humans you do have
direct contact with in the here-and-now
they may never be able to transform
another person's prospects entirely or
rescue the whole species from its
Agony's but they can smile and stop for
five minutes to chat to a neighbor about
the weather their modesty around what's
pasa
makes them acutely sensitive to the
worth of the little things that can be
done before today is over the Frank
person has a high degree of confidence
as to their ability to judge relatively
quickly and for the very long term
what's right and wrong about a given
situation they feel they can tell who's
behaved well or badly and what the
appropriate course of action should be
around any dilemma this is what gives
them the confidence to get angry with
whatever strikes them as stupid and to
blow up bridges with people they've
become vexed with the polite person is
much more unsure they're conscious that
what they feel strongly about today
might not be what they end up thinking
next week they know how easily they can
get it all wrong so they're drawn to
deploy softening tentative language and
holding back on criticism whenever
possible
they'll suggests that an idea might not
be quite right they'll say that a
project is attractive but that it could
be interesting to look at alternatives
as well they'll consider that an
intellectual opponent may well have a
point they are just lying or dodging
tough decisions their behavior is
symptomatic of a new ask belief that few
ideas are totally without merit no
proposals are 100% wrong and almost no
one is entirely foolish they know good
and bad are deviously entangled their
politeness is a logical careful response
to the complexity that they identify in
the world both the Frank and the polite
person of course have important lessons
to teach us but it may be that at this
point in history
it's the distinctive wisdom of the
polite person that is actually the one
most ripe for rediscovery and that may
have the most effective power to take
the edge off some of the more brutal
aggressive and in the end
counterproductive consequences of the
raining Frank ideology
you